[Music]
[Music]
a few minutes ago
the european parliament and the council
reached an agreement to transform the
european asylum support office
into a european union agency for asylum
the new agency is a key initiative
under the new pact on migration asylum
and it will help make asylum procedures
in the member states of higher quality
more uniform and faster
the agency will have a reserve of 500
experts
ready to be deployed as part of asylum
support teams at the request of member
states
the agency will also have an enhanced
role when it comes to monitoring and
reporting
on member states asylum and reception
systems making sure that standards and
practices are consistent throughout
europe
and fully in line with euro finally the
agency will play an important role
in capacity building in non-eu countries
today's agreement
is the second legislative agreement on
the new pact proposals
following agreement on the blue card
directive in may
a number of operational aspects of the
new pact are also already being
implemented
for example on the external dimension of
migration policy returns
and the deployment of european border
and coast guard standing call
negotiations on the remaining
legislative proposals continue in the
european parliament and the council
the commission warmly welcomes this
agreement which signals a pragmatic
step-by-step approach towards achieving
a more efficient and sustainable eu
migration management system
you will find more information in the
press release we are about to publish
thank you very much albert
let's remember that we have interpreters
who need to interpret everything
that we are saying so let's not speed up
too much
when we are making announcements i now
call christian who has news on our
contribution
to make traveling easier during this
summer
yes thank you eric
uh yesterday commissioners raindus paton
and
kyrie aquita sent a letter to the 27 eu
member states
calling for a timely and consistent
implementation
of the updated recommendation on the
coordination
of free movement restrictions in the eu
and on the eu digital
covert certificate the commission
strongly encourages member states to
implement the recommendation
as soon as possible in particular they
should ensure
the travel exemptions for fully
vaccinated and recovered persons
to ensure family unity and apply the
updated color coding
of the ectc map this should
be best done before the first of july to
ensure
that measures are in line with the eu
digital covert certificate
we of course must also remain vigilant
of the delta variant and also for that
coordination is essential the commission
also encourages member states to swiftly
progress with the technical rollout
until the 1st of july
also to avoid disruptions national
authorities should remain in close
contact
with the different actors in the travel
sector
finally we need to give citizens the
confidence to
travel travel abroad this summer for
that they need
clear and timely information
therefore the commissioners call on the
ministers to provide
regular updates to the reopen eu
platform which will be
an obligation under the new regulation
we will continue
to work closely with member states to
ensure all of us
can find some well-deserved rest in
these summer months
thank you here here thank you very much
christian now let's continue with stefan
for an announcement on treatment
against the coronavirus
thank you very much eric good morning
everybody today the eu strategy on covet
19 therapeutics
is delivering its first outcome i'm
indeed happy to announce
the first portfolio of five therapeutics
that could soon be available to treat
patients across
the eu four of these therapeutics
are monoclonal antibodies which are
currently under
rolling review with the european
medicines agency
the fifth one is a immunosuppressant
which already has a marketing
authorization but this marketing
authorization could be extended to also
include the treatment of kovic 19
patients
by october the commission will drop a
portfolio of at least
10 potential covit 19 therapeutics
building on the work of the newly
established expert group
hong kovic 19 variants and of course
the selection will happen will be
objective and
totally science-based more info
will be available on your trusted
friends the daily news where you will
find
a press release and questions and
answers thank you
merci beaucoup stefan
connors
[Music]
uh
so i'm happy to confirm that on thursday
1st of july we will be
welcoming you back in person here in the
press room
the number of seats will be limited to
69 to ensure physical distancing
and respect of all sanitary measures
starting thursday we will therefore
employ a hybrid
system which means that we will take
questions from journalists who
are in the room and uh from those who
continue to take part
uh to the midday briefing through our
interaxial
system for press conferences
by the president or commissioners when
we expect a greater number of
journalists to come the spp
will apply a system of pre-registration
which will work on a first come
first served basis
on the other hand for normal midday
briefings
no prior registration will be necessary
but we will only let
69 journalists into the room
um you have received in fact detailed
information
regarding the re reopening and the
related
procedures and you can find them i hope
it's here yes
you can find them also online on the spp
website
and at the end of our
daily news of course we're all looking
forward very much
to this i will not be present personally
on that day since it is the college
visit
to the slovenian presidency so dana will
have the pleasure
of welcoming you in the press room once
again
extremely important
[Music]
[Music]
only
me
and thank you for giving me the flow i
have a
question about the legislative issue
which is related i think to climate
change
and european deal as you may know
last week an international expert panel
came up with a
definition of the recognition of ecocide
crime against the environment against
the planet
to be amended as part of the statutes of
the international criminal
court and i also know that let's say a
coalition of
members of the european parliament are
supporting this
and i come together to try to push for
this in the parliament
i don't know if the commission has any
position on this issue
but i would very much like to know what
you think about it
and if it's something which the
commission might consider to
to to legislate about thank you
legislation about ecocide
vivian
good afternoon diamond thanks a lot for
this question
well as you know for the commission this
fight against climate change and global
warming is of the utmost
priority and with this in mind we have
put in place the european green deal
that in order to make sure that europe
reaches
climate neutrality by 2050 we have now
this enshrined in eu laws already with
the climate act that has been
passed now all the legislative steps
through the european parliament and the
and the council
and is now a legal obligation for the
member states to make sure that we will
get
to this climate neutrality by 2050 as
well as
have the new ambition of reaching
to much more higher cuts in our
greenhouse gas emissions by 2030 and
with that we will come forward with a
big legislative package on the 14th of
july
which shows exactly how we're going to
get there how we will achieve
in cutting our greenhouse gas
emissions by more than well at least 55
percent compared to the 1990 levels
so we're taking all these steps within
the european union
obviously it's also a lot of work that
we're doing with our international
partners we are preparing for the uh
for the events at the united nations
level both for the um
for the conference of parties on climate
change
in november as well as to the equally
important one on biodiversity in
october and our aim there is also to
work
on reaching a global consensus to act on
these matters but when it comes to both
climate change as well as to
biodiversity
so these are the steps that we are
taking already
very briefly when it comes to the issue
that you raised that has been discussed
last week
or that has been that has come also to
our knowledge last week
then certainly this is something which
is an idea which is
uh it's being discussed in many fora
including the european parliament
and then we'll see what the next steps
will be on that thank you
thank you very much vivian are there
other questions for vivian
on climate or environmental related
issues please only keep your hand raised
if it is
on this
fabio is your you have a question on
climate change or environmental
protection
or environmental protection oh yes
please
go ahead oh thank you so my question is
on a single use
plastic plastic plastic directive
just to know what's the state of play
of the work on implementing acts
on calculation method methodology
and do you think that it will be
approved
before the 3rd of july
thank you thanks fabia indeed the
single-use plastic
directive will now enter fully into
force or the rather the transposition
deadline for the member states is this
3rd of july
so this coming saturday what it means is
that member states
have had to put in place by the 3rd of
july
the rules nationally to implement the
directive the directive
as you might remember was one of the key
deliverables and
in in the green portfolio for the last
mandate
and what it says is that we looked and
analyzed what are the
most used most present single-use
plastic items
in the oceans and we decided to ban
those
so there are almost i think 10 items
including
singles cutleries different versions of
single-use plastic
which are which will now be banned
um to be brought into the european
market as of uh
as of this saturday and
and this with this step what we're
trying to do is
minimize as much as possible the um
the proliferation of single-use plastic
in the global oceans
now when it comes to these items that
will be banned from
from this saturday these are all items
for which there are affordable
and available alternatives non-plastic
that are there we have um
we are now discussing this with the
member states we are following up
also where they are with these
transpositions so i'm sure next week
i'll be able to give you a more clear
answer on that what i'd refer you now to
is the website on your lex you have a
database which shows where member states
are registered there are laws of
transposition
and you will see there what the state of
play is
that as far as they are on
on implementing these rules but indeed
thanks for bringing this to the
attention it's the third of july which
is the big date for banning the
further singlious plastic in the
european union
thank you very much vivian i see
no further questions on this issue no
further hand
raised so i go back to raf who was the
second person to have raised his hand
yes hello hello everyone i have a
question about what
vice president sheena said about the
euro championships
yesterday where he warned them against
the
virus the new variant and against
holding the semis and finals
at the wembley uh before a large
audience
can i take it is this now the commission
officially asking uh your wafer to
reconsider
this and not hold and not hold it before
a big public or could you please explain
to me exactly what the commission wants
and also one word of apology i've been
away for a month so i
do i hope you haven't had to deal with
this issue with nauseam for the past two
weeks
thank you um this is a health related
question so i passed the floor to stefan
thank you very much i'm not sure i can
add a lot to what has been said i think
what is very important to take into
account
is that we are in a situation where we
have a virus and where the variant is
out there we have to be extremely
careful
with this variant with the transmission
of this variant and it's very important
in this
context that we bear in mind the
different
guidance for instance that is out there
coming from the ecdc for instance
with regard to the organization of
events putting people together
so i think it is very important that
member states who are in the end
obviously responsible for the
organization of
such events bear in mind these very
important
recommendations and follow the caution
that is called for by
the vice president and for instance by
the ecdc thank you
thank you very much do we have other
health related questions
for stefan today please only keep your
hand raised if it's on this
health related issues
jillian
thanks so much um i have a question on
the therapy announcement
um in the may strategy document for
um the commission's uh plans to purchase
that um
excuse me therapies um the commission
wrote that they were in talks to
purchase
uh three coveted 19 medicines that were
awaiting marketing authorization
i was wondering if you could give us a
kind of state of play of where those
purchasing conversations are
and when we'll have some kind of update
on whether the eu is purchasing any of
these medicines
thank you thank you julian stefan
thank you very much julia maybe i could
refer you to
our very good questions and answers
which have been published on the daily
news where
you will see an overview of what we're
doing in the area of
joint procurement you know that uh on
the 8th of october 2020
we signed a joint procurement framework
contract with gilead for the supply of
500 000 treatment courses of
um rendezvous we also know that it's
explained
in our q a that since last october the
commission
signed over 70 joint 70s or 7-0
joint procurement contracts for 19
medicines
including analgesics antibiotics muscle
relaxers and aesthetics resuscitation
including dexa medicine to treat
more severe covet 19 cases in
intensive care units of course the joint
procurement
is a mechanism that is at the disposal
of the commission in a member states and
we can always
further build or conclude further new
framework contracts in the context of
such joint procurement
to purchase or to reserve rather the
purchase
of therapeutics and other medicines
that member states may feel to be useful
thank you thank you
um tommaso you have a question on health
related issues
yes hi thank you for the floor uh well
just to come back to the question which
was asked before
i didn't really understand are you in
touch with
wefa uh yesterday vice president
skinners addressed
the issue uh in the parliament of this
finals final and semi-finals that will
be played
in wembley um i think is not
uh is not uh uh you are aware of the
epidemiological situation and uh
is i don't have to remind it here so uh
did you get in touch with the president
of wafa and
if yes did he assure you that the
situation we will
properly address thank you thank you
stefan
uh i thank you i'm afraid i'm not in a
position to
add much more to what i've said before i
think that the commission has made and
the vice president has made
his position clear which is that it's
very important
to be very careful given the spread of
the variance and the fact that we're
still in this fight against
the the vaccine and i'm afraid at this
stage i will have to leave it at that
thank you
thank you are there other questions on
health related issues please only keep
your hand raised if it is
on health khalid you have a question on
health
oh no not on health i have a question on
other subjects yes then please
unraise your hand thank you to help me
manage the press conference
we'll come back to you at a later stage
jonathan
my
[Music]
television thanks for the floor i have a
just a
short question regarding a letter
written by
six meps and addressed to president
from the line and sean michelle they are
accusing slovenian prime minister of
obstructing the work of the
european public prosecutor's office and
interference in the in the nomination
process of the
delegated prosecutors uh and they are
demanding
uh to suspend eu payments to slovenia to
insist on the
proposed candidates to be appointed and
dementor slovenia appoints its delegated
prosecutors
immediately my question is can you
confirm that you received this letter
and what is your command
thank you i personally cannot confirm
that we have received
the letter question do you have any
information on this
no i'm afraid i can also not confirm
anything on this on this letter such
of course receiving a lot of
a lot of letters but let us check
if this has been received i can maybe
clarify or
say something on a different letter
in relation to that and and tell you
that the commission of course remains in
contact
uh with slovenia on on the matter of the
nomination of the delegated prosecutors
for the european public prosecutors
office and commissioner reinders
actually wrote a letter
to the slovenian justice minister on
this to the news living and justice
minister
on this last week reminding again that
this is a matter of the of the utmost
urgency
so we are continuing to be in touch
and to making very clear to the
slovenian government that it is
important
to to solve and address this issue very
soon
thank you christian so are there other
questions for question
on rule of law issues
that is not the case so we go to khalid
uh i would like to ask human
alarm at the detention and torture of
children and indian administrative
kashmir
and particularly secretary general
antonio guterres
request india to to prevent
this kind of atrocities in kashmir
so what is the view of european union on
this report
thank you a question for nabila
but we will see whether we are informed
of this report or if we can come back to
you
but please
thanks khalid and i'm sorry i'm not
aware of this report so i'm afraid i
will get back to you
on on this report specifically
okay are there other questions for
nabila on
external relations on foreign affairs
issues
that is not the case any other issue for
us today
fabio
yes hi again uh i have a question
on covid's correct uncovered
certificate just to know
if the covet certificates made in
western balkan will be
re recognized in the eu
if not why and what the commission
is doing to do so thank you
thank you christian
thank you fabio for for the question um
what i can what i can say at this stage
is that um
i think i said before that we have uh of
course
requests from many uh from many parts
of the world for the possibility
of of this of this recognition of
possible adequacy decisions
um we will have to see for which
which countries this will be possible
but what i can say is that uh also from
the from the western balkans countries
we have
been approached on this matter
on a more general level you know that
there are
there is the option on under the eu
digital corporate certificate
for uh people from third countries that
which includes of course the the western
balkans
um to obtain a certificate
uh if they have been if they can
provide sufficient proof of a relevant
vaccination under the certificate
regulation
to a member state they are traveling to
so this is this is already um
already possible now and whether
whether there will be further
negotiations on
on possible adequacy decisions will
remain open at this stage but there have
been contacts
thank you christian are there other
questions
on the digital certificate for christian
today
christian christians
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
description
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
variant area um
[Music]
come at an emergency brake
system
[Music]
[Music]
delta
[Music]
while we must stand ready to reintroduce
public health measures
if needed including by making use of the
emergency brake
coordination remains essential it is
important that any triggering of the
emergency brake is communicated to the
commission
and to other member states as soon as
possible
member states should also follow the
approach agreed in the recommendation
taking
strict measures like guaranteeing but
avoiding travel bans
the german measures do not seem fully
aligned with it
yes thank you why why the german
measures are not fully aligned
thank you
well look um take a look at the at the
recommendation
which is quite clear what the measures
could be under an emergency brake
namely if i remember well
quarantine and end testing
which is which is what's what we have in
the in the recommendation
and as i mentioned uh
as we have consistently held
avoiding travel bans but
again this is a matter that is now and
and
i would also of course invite you to to
check with the council on the discussion
that was held yesterday and
and on possible future follow-up um
as this is as this is foreseen in the
recommendation that
if a member state uh wants to make use
of the emergency brake then this
should be uh coordinated coordinated and
discussed in a structured way
um at member state level
thank you i see
no further questions on
this issue are there other issues for us
today
catherine hello
hello eric uh i just wanted to ask
in relation to tomorrow's uh
announcement
by marcelkovic i mean it's widely
anticipated
that extension will be granted
to uh some of the the arrangements
uh for chilled meat for example
but i noticed that today british
parliamentarians
have written to the prime minister
asking for an extension to the deadline
of the eu
settlement scheme and they're very
concerned
that that many that many people will not
not be able to sign up on time and their
status will not be secured
and that this could have very
far-reaching consequences
and in particular there's concern that
children and more vulnerable groups will
be
particularly damaged
by this and so i was just wondering in
exchange for the extensions that are
being granted
to the uk to meet its um
obligations under the withdrawal
agreement
and tca will the eu
also be pressing for eu citizens
to get i receive uh
an extension to their right to apply for
settled status it seemed like um
that would be a fair exchange and
in the withdrawal agreement negotiations
the
the rights of eu citizens living
in the uk was a top concern thank you
thank you catherine i think that you are
piling up the hypothesis here and as you
know
that is something that we are not
comfortable with in terms of
of answering in particular when it comes
to the
uh the decisions which you say the
commission is going to take
so i'm afraid we will certainly not go
into details
on this but i will give the floor to dan
to see if he has
any other comment to make
yep thanks very much eric and hi
catherine thanks for your question
eric summed up very very well on the
first leg of your question catherine
on the vice president shefkovich's press
conference tomorrow
um i think you would have seen some of
the statements that he has made over the
past couple of days
with regards to implementation of the
protocol we are open to finding
solutions
we're working really really hard on that
and we're in contact with member states
the european parliament and of course
the uk on this
at this exact moment in time mike i
cannot provide more details
than that secondly on citizens rights
you're right in saying that the the
deadline for applying for settlement
status um
is the end of the month um tomorrow
we've been working extremely hard
to raise awareness to make sure that
people in the uk and right across the
european union
are aware of this deadline we have been
providing support
we've been providing help in so far as
possible uh
with regards to the letter that you
mentioned ie i'm not aware of that and i
i cannot comment on it obviously
but i'll just say just that we are
working as hard as we can to spread the
message about this deadline
let this midday briefing also serve as a
message
to eu citizens in the uk and uk citizens
in europe on their need to follow these
issues
very very carefully and to sign up as
quickly
as possible catherine you have a
follow-up
i mean we see that the
parliamentarians are very concerned
because they have received reports
that these very very vulnerable groups
um
children children leaving care are
particularly a question and would it not
be appropriate
for the eu to try and intervene
to extend that deadline or to
plead for the mitigating circumstances
for these individuals
catherine thank you very much for your
question again but we will not be
commenting on quid pro quo's that need
to be made there is indeed as you said a
press conference tomorrow
by vice president sefkovic and i would
ask you to address your questions
to him during that press conference
tomorrow
are there other questions for us today
that is not the case let me thank you
therefore for your participation
and i will see you tomorrow for the
college readout
bon appetit